just want to hear a little bit about the
marketing and promotion that you put in
to the to the chutes and ladders the the
webseries you talk about the the work
that you did there and and have you used
this series in promotion with the
Kickstarter release as well well I think
with chutes and ladders that was that
was really a lesson in what not what not
to do I think we with that we went in
with a we went in with a plan of what
what we thought we should do um but we
didn't we didn't necessarily execute on
that plan um just for a number of
reasons one we were um we had a release
schedule with called cast and I was
editing up until you know the night
before those needed to to be uploaded so
we didn't we didn't do everything we
wanted to but we at least had a sense of
you know coming into the the Kickstarter
campaign um you know where we could look
and where we what we what we could do I
mean honestly I think it came down to we
we had lost a lot of energy when we got
to end it but you know because we had
put so much time and effort into
actually shooting it you know I mean
there are definitely negatives to beam
you know DIY and and we that was the
biggest lesson that we learned like that
you can't actually do it all yourself
and so when we got to post it was
exhausting and and like we had a plan of
what we should do but it was just
there's just no way we could do it after
having spent the last two three months
actually shooting it in between jobs and
I mean everyone was working for free
including doctors at that point and and
you know getting to the post part of it
I mean it was just he was editing it
himself to and you know my my brother
was doing music but it was the first
time he had done music so there was just
a lot of first across the board from
other people as well so I think you know
a lot of things kind of can just fell
through um and then as far as um using
it in this campaign we we actually
haven't and the reason the reason for
that now
you know in hindsight we we probably
should have owned we should have tied it
in a little more um the reason we didn't
is because our plan was to have the new
episodes we're gonna release the two new
episodes that you know look look nice
and pretty like we wanted to show our
are you know raising our level of
production value um only because we were
delayed in getting those episodes out we
had no basis of comparison so we weren't
able to you know how we known that we're
gonna be delayed on getting those
episodes done in time then I think we we
might have planned to use more of the
old episodes but since we went in
thinking that we're gonna have those new
episodes you know we wanted to focus on
those new episodes because there's
there's quite a bit of contrast between
how those look and how our season 1
episodes looking at and and I think
because we did go with the Future format
instead of the web series I think that's
why we kind of you know we started
initially telling people that oh we're
converting the web series to a feature
we're doing it but honestly what
remained of it was just the characters
and the idea and and that was about it
so it just didn't feel like the same
thing you know you even changed the name
and like there was a lot of there was a
lot of things um that didn't kind of I
guess carry over so we didn't know how
valuable it would be to to really pull
in the the little tiny audience that we
had from the web series to begin with
rather than just kind of start over
having had that experience you know to
importantly we're sure if that would be
confusing to because you know what we're
doing is very different from what that
was and we even recast one in the lead
role so it would it would definitely
look very different and so ideally the
campaign is 32 and a half days ideally
when did you want to release the to the
two webisodes about halfway through
we're gonna release the first and then
with about a week we can have to go
we're gonna release the second and what
factored into sort of that that
decision-making into in terms of like
you know why why say okay we're going
halfway through and then and then sort
of like as the campaign ending as
opposed to all right we're going to do
these first we're gonna release them
we're gonna get as many people with a
see them you know first and then we're
gonna do a campaign you know and bring
hopefully bring some of the people these
new fans over to you know so what went
into that sort of strategy of like no
we're gonna actually release the
campaign first or launch convey first
and then release episodes thank you I
mean I think I guess we had originally
planned it as being part of the content
or part of that fits that we release
within the campaign and thinking like
okay we'll build up momentum in other
ways and then this will be sort of one
of those extra things are like oh and
here's another example of what we're
doing and and I think in retrospect in
me we were talking about this earlier
where him flee we were to do it over
again we probably would do it like that
and yeah I just think I think when we
originally went forward with it the the
thought was to have you know our pitch
was we had no budget but this is what we
can do with the budget so and here it is
only only that didn't work out and so
you know in hindsight you know maybe
releasing them building an audience to
do that and then and then launching one
might have made sense but we we thought
it would be at the time when we went
forward we thought it would be valuable
to have that as part of the as part of
the campaign content
you